Vìng ai hàng lâm thông em một sang nhận bộ trưởng lúc quan danh risk call đã có cuộc gặp không báo trước
với quan trinh hà tại thủ đô Abu đã bị cộ cá tiểu vương cuộc ở rộ thống nhất
Đây là một phần trong lúc ngoại gà còn thôi của chính quyền tổng thủ đúng năng trăm
Nhằm thúc đầy thảo thật trong lức trình xe sợ u cuaina
On risk call sự kiến sẽ gặp cả phái đón u cuaina khi ở UIA trong bộ cạnh Washington và kia vẫn còn khóc biệt lớn
liên quan tế mạnh kế hoại hòa bình hàng b hitam điểm
Dương thảo góc giòn miệng để xuất UCA UCoiina, giữa thế này thổ bị hạn chế quy mục cộng đối và phải từ bỏ một tiêu ra nhập tổ chức
Hế ước mọi là tài dùng nát頭, sau cuộc gặp ngoại trưởng miế UCoiina tại trên nè vào thủ xí
Tổng thống vô lâu đi mê dên sĩ cho biết, bản thầm nhật tinh trình sau vòng học này đã bộ xung nhiều điểm đúng
Nhưng các nội dùng nhẹ cảm vẫn tổn tảy và có thể ông dên sĩ sẽ phải bản chức tiếp trụng với ông đúng đúng đúng năng trăm
Trong khi đóng, hoại trưởng ngay sẽ gọi là rốt khẳng định, mắt sơ vãng hoàn ngành kế hoại bản đầu và tinh bộ bất kỳ sử dụng thảo nào cũng cần phản anh sức đồng thuật
Mà tổng thống vấn đề mẹ bu tín và tổng thống Mỹ đồn trọng đả đạt được tải thử định Alaskar
Về phía trô ổng thống pháp ema nè mặt quân cạnh báo, phương tay không chấp nhận một nền hòa bình k yểu đô hàng
Những mạnh chỉ của quân nha mới có quyền quyết định về các nhận bộ lạnh thổ
Hình các nước trong liên mình tự nguyện ở ngộ uc quân nha rất đầu của ông Anh pháp, đất, dự kia n' học chức tuyến thảo lật nước tiếp theo
Thúc đầy một phản để sất đủ mạnh mẽ trong tổn này